hoy por hoy voy a compartir con ustedes
la historia del día de que por primera
vez en mi vida y decidí contratar un
servicio de mototaxi toda una aventura
porque jamás me había montado en una
moto como pasajero y jamás había tenido
la oportunidad de interactuar con un
motorizado porque como ustedes saben los
motorizados en venezuela tienen una fama
que no es muy buena que digamos
estamos más o menos a mediados del 2010
acaba de terminar de escribir un escrito
que tenía que llevar para los tribunales
con carácter de urgencia y al bajar a la
plaza altamira con la intención de
contratar un taxi me conseguí un tráfico
espantoso
en los niveles de estrés se me
dispararon entre exxon la idea de no
poder consignar el escrito a tiempo me
descontroló mientras evaluaban las
opciones que eran básicamente salí
corriendo y llegar al tribunal corriendo
montarme en un taxi en un carrito por
puesto o inclusive en el metro en la
esquina había una línea de mototaxis
donde el fiscal de la línea de mototaxis
estaba promocionando los servicios de
sus compañeros motociclistas
está utilizando una alarma y pegaba
gritos moto taxi moto taxi moto taxi y
en la mitad de ese alboroto decía cómo
resuelvo mi problema
enfrente había un mototaxista que estaba
a la vez echando piropos a una muchacha
que iba pasando y uno de ellos se me
acercó y me dijo doctor lo veo
preocupado para dónde va yo lo llevo
barato bueno se podrá imaginar la
cantidad de ideas que pasaron por mi
cabeza y bueno si me monto en el taxi
sin lugar a dudas llegó a tiempo al
tribunal pero además entonces empecé a
pensar cómo hago para no caerme de la
moto sin abrazar al motorizado
como hago para no involucrarme en un
accidente de motorizados
al mismo tiempo pensaba en todos los
riesgos que tienen que ver con el
estigma de los motorizados
eran hojas y ustedes sacan su teléfono y
le preguntan a google en este instante
porque los motorizados de venezuela son
famosos el comentario el primer
comentario que van a ver ahí es que es
este los motorizados en caracas son la
peor peste que circulan en las calles
imagínense eso
decidí la pregunta es de las 50 mil
lochas era me lanzó al agua yo a tratar
de que sientan en este instante lo que
yo sentí en ese momento
le voy a pedir que cierren los ojos sin
hacer trampas por favor
[Música]
ahora imaginen que están montados en un
avión a 2000 metros de altura y que
están a punto de hacer su primer salto
en paracaídas
listo visualizan ese susto
bueno ese fue el pánico que yo sentía en
el momento que estaba evaluando
contratada mi primer servicio de
mototaxi pero la idea de no llegar a los
tribunales a tiempo era no no era viable
había que consignar que ese escrito a
tiempo
me fui para los tribunales con el
motorizado el tipo de un experto
manejando motos consigne mi escrito a
tiempo regresamos y a las tres de la
tarde estaba sentado mi oficina el
servicio había sido maravilloso no lo
podía creer la conversación que estuve
con alberto ese día y el servicio que me
prestó fue tan bueno que ese día decidí
convertirme en un pasajero mototaxi
profesional empecé a moverme por toda
caracas con el servicio moto taxi para
ser más eficiente con mi tiempo nosotros
los abogados lo que hacemos vender
tiempo y en el camino empecé a conocer
una cantidad de motorizados
interesantísimos sus historias eran
increíbles y un día llegué a la
conclusión de que era sociológicamente
hablando era sumamente injusto el
estigma generalizado de los motorizados
entonces que hacer al respecto bueno en
ese momento
y de bueno vamos a conversar
y bueno el él
y empezamos a empezar a utilizar el
servicio
y empezamos a trabajar en la idea de
desarrollar una plataforma tecnológica
que conectará a los clientes y que le
permitiera a cualquier persona que
necesitara necesitará los servicios de
un moto emprendedor
y conectarse con esos fotos
emprendedores y al mismo tiempo que la
aplicación permitiera que esas
solicitudes viajaran a los teléfonos
inteligentes de los mensajeros y al
mismo tiempo que le permitiera a los
equipos de operaciones estos motorizados
supervisar esas solicitudes en tiempo
real utilizando la tecnología
en nuestro negocio en tu motorizado es
ayudar a la gente a simplificar su vida
y su negocio permitiéndole que se
conecten o permitiendo que resuelvan sus
problemas dándoles acceso a los
servicios útiles que prestan los moto
emprendedores lo segundo que hacemos
este motorizado es crear ocho
emprendedores que es un voto emprendedor
un voto emprendedor es un motorizado
honesto trabajador comprometido con la
excelencia con esta idea decidirse en
carne con los autorizados a validar la
idea les pareció fantástico la idea de
ponerse productivo con su moto en su
tiempo libre les pareció buenísima igual
pasó cuando me senté a conversar con los
clientes la idea de contratar a un
motorizado con un par de clics me
pareció buenísimo y además si el
motorizador a confiable entonces en ese
momento tomé la decisión de contratar a
un equipo de tecnología que casualmente
en ese momento estaba trabajando en las
oficinas de guairá
wayra es una empresa relacionada con
movistar del grupo telefónica españa que
a la vez en venezuela tiene una
aceleradora una incubadora de
emprendimientos que apoya a
emprendedores digitales como yo criollos
con financiamiento con espacio de
oficinas convento día a poner en marcha
sus proyectos en un espacio y unas
instalaciones espectaculares mis
reuniones de seguimientos con ese equipo
de tecnología eran en las oficinas de
guairá y cada vez que iba me enamoraba
del concepto guaira al punto que un día
dije oye vale la pena vamos a trabajar
aquí para convertir a tu motorizado en
una startup apoyada por esta aceleradora
entonces en diciembre del 2000 cap del
2012 más o menos decidimos postular el
proyecto pasamos el corte fuimos una de
las 17 de startups que fueron a la final
pinchamos nuestra idea de negocio a un
jurados y fue una de las ganadoras
bueno se podrán imaginar la alegría ese
día cuando ganamos ese premio
salimos a la calle a captar mensajeros
con un criterio de inclusión sólido está
buscando mensajeros con perfil
emprendedor que tuviesen madera para
convertirse en moto emprendedores
visitamos y fuimos a los sitios que
ustedes no se imaginan conversamos con
muchísimos motorizados
y estamos buscando en todos en el gran
reto era bueno como hacemos verdad para
evitar que nuestras plataformas se
incorporen mensajeros que sean manzanas
podridas que nos echan a perder los
negocios como hacemos para que sean
solamente emprendedores opa y confiables
evaluamos varias opciones y
desarrollamos una planilla de registro
que le impuso a los mensajeros una tarea
importantísima que era que tenían que
registrar o cargar en la planilla de
registro todos sus datos personales
todos los datos de su moto imágenes de
sus documentos personales e imágenes de
los documentos de su moto y ninguno de
esos documentos podría estar vencido
los resultados el filtro funciona muy
bien porque cada 100 mensajeros que
invitamos a la plataforma solamente 10
se registraban en la página
y sorprendentemente dos de esos diez
eran los que llenaban la planilla
completa
entonces a esos que llenaban la planilla
completa los invitamos una vez al mes a
unas reuniones de activación y de
educación
en esas reuniones les explicamos cómo
funcionaba nuestra aplicación móvil de
mensajero les explicamos por qué era
importante que respetaran las leyes de
tránsito alexander que nos está
acompañando acompañando hoy aquí era el
encargado de eso les explicamos por qué
explicamos cómo vender sus servicios y
cómo vender el servicio de tu motorizado
le explicábamos qué significa ser un
motor emprendedor o emprendedor y les
explicamos por qué era importante
prestar un servicio con un nivel de
calidad jamás visto en venezuela
en estas reuniones también aprovechamos
para tomarles una foto que incorpora
vamos a su perfil perfil digital
igualmente le hacíamos de tomamos las
huellas dactilares y toda esa
información la guardamos en nuestra
plataforma para imprimirle confianza a
nuestro servicio
de todas las actividades o iniciativas
de educación que nosotros implementamos
en tu motorizados quizás la más
maravillosa la que yo disfruté más fue
una oportunidad en donde como
facilitador ayudé a 20 de nuestros votos
emprendedores a construir el código de
ética del voto emprendedor eso es algo
que hicieron ellos solos yo simplemente
era el moderador de esta reunión de
lluvia de ideas
trabajamos en cuatro compromisos los
compromisos del voto emprendedor con los
clientes los compromisos del motor
emprendedor con el equipo de operaciones
de tu motorizado los compromisos del
motor emprendedor con el negocio y los
compromisos del monto emprendedor con
con el negocio o con sus compañeros moto
emprendedores
no se imaginan las reglas de principios
y valores que quedaron registradas en
este documento es un documento
maravilloso al punto que yo siento que
ese código de ética al como tú
emprendedor es una de las de la de las
razones por las cuales el proyecto en tu
motorizado ha tenido el éxito que ha
tenido
pero no era necesario solamente el
código tenía que haber una especie de
sanción o supervisión para que se
equivocará entonces como nuestros
clientes tenían la oportunidad de
evaluar a nuestros votos emprendedores
nosotros nos enteramos cuando un voto
emprendedor estaba haciendo mal su tarea
y en consecuencia sí claro que sí lo que
hacíamos en esos casos es que
desactivamos al mensajero y el mensajero
entonces se quedaba sin tener acceso a
la gallina de los huevos de oro y a los
beneficios que tú motorizado le brinda a
los motor emprendedores
este sistema de tener reglas un sistema
de evaluación y un sistema de sanción
justo y de premios vamos a ver adelante
ha tenido resultados maravillosos a la
fecha en tu motorizado nuestros
motorizados han hecho más de 100.000
entregas
y en esas 100.000 la entrega nunca se ha
desaparecido un motorizado que se haya
robado algo vaya a llegar a esa pregunta
a cualquiera de los courier de venezuela
ese resultado nos tiene muy contento lo
otro que nos tiene muy muy contento es
que hemos logrado que la prensa no
solamente hable de cosas malas de los
motorizados sino que también hable cosas
buenas en nuestra plataforma hay un
número importante de damas moto
emprendedoras y hay dos de ellas que son
famosas una la historia de una de ellas
fue publicada por la revista dominical y
la historia de una de otra de ellas fue
sacada al aire por el programa localidad
de globovisión
operando este negocio nos hemos dado
cuenta también que es súper importante
premiar la meritocracia y la excelencia
por eso es que nuestra plataforma cada
cierto tiempo determina cuál es el mejor
motor emprendedor de nuestra nuestro
servicio y a ese motor emprendedor con
el apoyo de yamaha le vendemos una moto
a presión lista no va a saquear y le
financiamos parte del precio de la moto
que ellos pagan con las vueltas que van
haciendo en la plataforma
hacer las cosas bien o es el compromiso
que han asumido los motor emprendedores
y nuestro equipo de hacer las cosas bien
ha traído como consecuencia que nuestros
clientes se sienten seguros contratando
a un motor emprendedor de nuestra
plataforma
nuestro nos encanta cuando nuestros
clientes comparten su felicidad en las
redes sociales los cual hacen con
relativa frecuencia
haber fundado tu motorizado y haber
estado encargado de la operación de este
negocio durante 45 años me ha permitido
ser un mejor ser humano
hoy soy una persona muchísimo más
empática hoy tengo mejor vocación de
servicio y hoy me gusta más que nunca
ayudar a la gente a progresar
estos resultados maravillosos que hemos
logrado con el gremio motorizado
me animan muchísimo a seguir trabajando
y aportando mi grano de arena para
acercar al venezolano a principios y
valores que en venezuela no se promueven
y tampoco se aplauden también me
permiten decirles hoy sin temor a
equivocarme que resultados parecidos se
pueden lograr con personas de cualquier
otro sector de nuestra población
la familia de tu motorizado crece todos
los días en esa familia interactuamos
cientos de clientes y usuarios cientos
de motos emprendedores un equipo
profesional de altísimo desempeño y
muchísimos colaboradores que han
permitido que con su aporte el éxito de
nuestro proyecto
estamos animados con los resultados que
hemos logrado
hemos descubierto que trabajar o sea que
los los negocios de economía
colaborativa como puede ser tu
motorizado como huber como herb y andy
son ecosistemas en donde esos son
negocios en donde se fortalecen y
promueven valores y principios sólidos
los ecosistemas en donde las las reglas
la evaluación la confianza
la excelencia son súper importantes
ojalá con ocasión de esta charla algunos
de ustedes se motiven a involucrarse con
este mundo tan interesante
con esto termino yo los quiero invitar a
que hagamos equipo para fomentar la idea
de que la gente asuma como estilo de
vida anclarse en principios y valores
sólidos y que hagamos todo lo necesario
para que el interior de nuestra familia
en el interior de nuestras escuelas y
universidades y en la interior de
nuestras instituciones públicas y
privadas con las cuales tengamos
contacto colaboremos para reescribir o
para repotenciar la identidad del
venezolano gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]